leipzig eine großstadt die wächst und
sich ständig verändert die viele städte
weltweit
auch hier gibt es die unsichtbare gefahr
feinstaub
in der lützner straße gibt es besonders
viel feinstaub eine enge straße mit sehr
viel verkehr
die vielen autos hinter größte probleme
kein guter ort zum wohnen sagt ulrich
frank physiker und gesundheitsforscher
der sich seit jahren mit feinstaub
beschäftigt zu den hauptverkehrszeiten
die strafen richtig zu und entsprechend
viel mit tieren auch die folge
das ist einmal der staub der
aufgewirbelt und woche zum glück muss
auch gleich reifen bremsen abtrieb und
das ist auch noch das aus dem auspuff
kommen
besonders gefährlich sind ausgerechnet
die party gilt für die bisher keine
grenzwerte festgelegt worden sind und
die besonders klein sind ultrafeine die
filter scheibe links ist neu die andere
aus der messstation zeigt was ich allein
an kleinen partikeln an nur einem tag an
sammelt wie nicht gut aus und hat folgen
ein jahr lang haben die forscher
sämtliche rettungseinsätze in leipzig
ausgewertet und festgestellt die menge
ultrafeine feinstaubpartikel besonders
hoch müssen mehr menschen schnell ins
krankenhaus
an vielen orten weltweit sind die
feinstaubwerte noch höher als hier
wenn wir jetzt in andere länder schauen
von leuchten nach indien china oder
verschiedene entwicklungsländer haben
top gewaltig hohe erkrankungsraten durch
diese schlechte luft also an ein extrem
erhöhtes sterberisiko und risiko für
verschiedene erkrankungen das geht hin
von kurzzeit effekten also
mit atemwegserkrankungen herz kreislauf
erkrankung aber auch langzeiteffekte das
sind zum beispiel krebserkrankungen die
forscher haben sich auch mit feinstaub
in innenräumen beschäftigt sie wollten
wissen ob kinder durch mehr feinstaub
ein höheres risiko haben an bronchitis
zu erkranken
das risiko ist tatsächlich erhöht wenn
zb in der wohnung geraucht wird oder
außerhalb viel verkehr ist denn beides
lässt die konzentration der ultrafeinen
partikel ansteigen
die wissenschaftler haben auch
untersucht wo in der stadt die
feinstaubbelastung hoch und wo sie
gering ist
wenn ich mir zum beispiel diesen
wunderschönen weißen cream zug hier in
leipzig anschaut dann ist das nicht nur
eine quelle von sauerstoff sondern ist
auch ein großer fisch luftkorridoren mit
dem schadstoff abtransportiert und
zwischen voran transportiert werden
können auch eine offene bebauung senkt
die feinstaubbelastung gegen bessere
durchlüftung und weniger verkehr
interessant für stadtplaner weltweit man
kann mit einfachen mitteln auch gerade
im schnell wachsenden metropolen über
dritten welt fragen
ich wollte so oder so bauen dann eine
peinlichkeit wirklich hohe belastungen
habe deutlich reduziert umweltzonen
verhindern dass fahrzeuge die besonders
viel ultrafeine partikel frei setzen in
die innenstädte kommen
insofern helfen sie gegen feinstaub sagt
ulrich frank aber weltweiten in den
städten noch sehr viel mehr passieren
manchen städten hilft sicher den
öffentlichen personennahverkehr zu
vorteil von anderen städten hilft die
bebauung so anzupassen dass ich eine
bessere durchlüftung haben habe in
anderen wiederum hilft es industrie
sauberer zu machen
weniger feinstaub in städten wäre also
möglich
ulrich frank hat einen weg gefunden in
die stadt der zukunft in der man
gefahrlos partnern kann
[Musik]